Українці переплачують за молоко і змушені
менше його споживати, б’є на сполох Асоціація виробників молока.
Вони стверджують, що ставка ПДВ
на молочні продукти в Україні є найвищою серед
європейських країн і становить 20%, тоді як у Німеччині - 7%,
у Франції - 5,5%, а в Польщі взагалі - 5%.
Найдешевше молоко у Німеччині коштує
60-70 євроцентів за літр, тобто 20-22 гривні.
Стільки ж або навіть і більше за молоко платять українці.
А ціна молока у поляків взагалі у півтора рази дешевше, ніж в Україні.
Податок на додану вартість - найбільше джерело поповнення держбюджету.
Коли ви купуєте щось у магазині чи замовляєте якусь послугу
майже все це обкладається ПДВ.
В Україні - три ставки цього податку: 20 відсотків, 7 та 0.
Так от молоко та молочні продукти оподатковуються за найвищою ставкою.
Втім, у Данії ця ставка ще вища - аж 25 відсотків
на всі групи товарів, включаючи і "молочку".
У решті країн ЄС для молока справді діє знижена ставка оподаткування -
в середньому 5-7 відсотків, за винятком Фінляндії - там 14.
Це можна перевірити у відповідному списку Єврокомісії.
У Німеччині ПДВ діє вже рівно півстоліття.
І його тут називають найбільш нелогічним і непрозорим податком.
Є дві ставки: 19 і 7 відсотків.
Молокопродукти і зокрема коров'яче молоко
справді мають знижену ставку - 7 відсотків.
Тоді як соєве молоко - вже 19.
Корм для собак - 7 відсотків, а дитяче харчування - 19.
Також дивно, чому кава у зернах має пільгове оподаткування,
а розчинна кава - найвищу ставку ПДВ.
На думку експертів, одна з причин такого різнобою,
бо одні групи продуктів і товарів вдалося пролобіювати
і внести до пільгового списку, а інші - ні.
Українським молочникам радять активніше ініціювати
зміни до оподаткування щодо молока, адже воно є в переліку
соціально значущих продуктів для населення.
Ставка ПДВ на молочні продукти в Україні
не є найвищою серед європейських країн.
Найвища у Данії - 25 відсотків.
Але українська у порівнянні справді одна з найвищих.
У більшості країн ЄС діє пільгова ставка для молока і молочної продукції,
яка вдвічі-тричі, а в деяких країнах і в 4 рази нижча, ніж в Україні.
Водночас, ПДВ - далеко не єдина причина,
чому українці переплачують за молоко.
На ціну впливає і зростання вартості газу та електрики,
і висока інфляція, а головне - велика кількість посередників-спекулянтів,
які скуповують у селян продукцію за безцінь, а потім
накручують ціну і перепродають.